[Music]
Megan Markel already has her beautiful
engagement ring from Prince Harry but
there's still plenty of wonder about
Markel's other sparkles including people
trying to figure out which priceless
tiara she'll wear on the big royal
wedding day so we are here at house of
gerard in london longtime jeweler to the
royal family we've got a private
appointment to talk tiaras and just
stare at some diamonds House of garrard
has been in London for centuries they
made none other than Princess Diana's
iconic engagement ring
Prince Charles kind of works with the
garage to create you know it's a very
classic Greek but to create the classic
ring that he wanted so he picked the
stone the main stone which is sapphire
they've also made Tiaras for the royal
family including the Cambridge lovers
not worn by Diana and Kate Middleton but
the family has many crowns so which one
will Megan Don
it appears and I'm again I'm only
speculating a bit here that there's sort
of also a tradition of the Queen giving
this gift of a of a tiara of something
from her collection so so maybe that's a
really nice from the mother-in-law kind
of thing a lot of people have wondered
if we might see her wear the Spencer
tiara which has not been worn since
Princess Diana's death well that
wouldn't be probably be up there when
the odds I would say but I'd say it's
probably a contender and I think people
would embrace that and be enthusiastic
about it and the story because you know
all these things are really about
stories stories that the pieces of
jewelry just collect they become sort of
icons of style which all about Megan say
and she's worn she's wants some sort of
dainty but some more edgy pieces in the
past
and like to see that carry on as well
when it comes to royal weddings there's
the diamond rings the priceless tiaras
and of course the dress we are here in
London and went to see none other than
Elizabeth Emanuel the woman behind
Princess Diana's iconic dress of course
to talk who she thinks will have
designed Megan markle's and get all the
secrets on exactly how a royal wedding
day
goes off without a hitch every time
there's a royal wedding are you know it
brings me back to those years ago when
we did Princess Diana's dress yeah of
course I have to ask you who do you
think it's going to be I think it's
probably Ralph Andrew so well they do
could sure they do beautiful clothes and
she's worn them before so you know I
think that with Diana she chose us
because she was used to the designs that
we did she liked them felt comfortable
and I think probably the same thing will
be you know with Megan but some people
think in a tribute to Diana but Megan
may put pieces of Diana's dress the
dress you made in her dress have you
heard this at all I think I'm Dinah's
dresses is owned by the boys now so you
know they've got it there maybe they
will put a little bit in the dress there
are a lot of logistics for the royal
wedding day Emanuel revealed the secrets
behind everything going smoothly well
we've done a practice run of putting
Diana into the coach wearing a calico 12
but we didn't really take into account
the train there was 25 foot train you
can imagine it was a bit of a crush so
when she came out the coach it was you
know a bit of a shot for us to see the
creases that we took smelling salts
along in case she felt faint we made a
separate skirt so just in case she was
drinking coffee or something and spilt
it down the front of the dress we had a
spare dress no so we tried to think of
everything even what if it rains so we
did a parasol in the matching taffeta
there has also been talked that Megan
might wear the same tiara that Diana
wore could you see that happening it
would be beautiful that suspense so
tiara and it would be lovely and I I
hope she wears wears it on the day you
know because it kind of completes the
outfit doesn't it that would be
wonderful to see that again yeah she's
got a lot of style
she's sort of because she she's a bit
older than Diana was you know she's had
time to develop
and she's comfortable in front of the
cameras she knows what suits her I think
we should look forward to seeing a
wedding dress with a lot of fashion
content you know unexpected and upbeat
but still very elegant you know and it's
got a bit of history behind it so it'll
be very interesting she's got great
style Emanuel is now working on a new
line of her own wedding gowns glamorous
red carpet dresses and more so you've
done a little bit of a rendering of what
you could see Megan wearing
yes so this is um this kind of things
that we do here and picking from that
collection there's one shape that I
think would look amazing on her because
she's got the most beautiful figure
amazing legs I thought wouldn't it be
cool
Prince Harry and Megan Markos big royal
wedding day is Saturday May 19th and et
has been here in England where we'll
continue to bring you all the latest
reporting and most glamorous details and
now I gotta go get to Windsor
[Music]